that was amazing amazing that was  amazing  amazing so Joey those t-shirts prove  that everything we suspected about  Twitter that they're all woke doped it's  true they had these shirts all what were  they for listen what I love about the  story is knowing that Elon Musk he may  sell them for a prophet he's a  businessman he might send them as  parting gifts to the people that left  but what I hope is that those those  t-shirts go and live in some Third World  Village and this parallel universe where  like the Phillies won the World Series  they all have the t-shirts you know yeah  right that's where that's where woke is  going to go to die yeah you know it's  just it's done it's amazing hey Sean  Hannity here hey click here to subscribe  to Fox News YouTube page and catch our  hottest interviews and most compelling  analysis you will not get it anywhere  else